et le moment n'est pas à la polémique
mais à l'aide au personnel médical
c'est en tout cas l'avis de jérôme marty
les médecins généralistes président de
l'union française pour une médecine
n'est pas écouté et politiques peuvent
se questionner entre eux cette espèce de
petit monde autarcique ça le regarde
nous à la limite ça ne nous concerne pas
ce qui nous concerne c'est les réponses
aux questions qu'on pourra leur poser
nous on se considère dans beaucoup
d'endroits comme abandonnée on n'a pas
de moyens d'autres de protection vous le
savez on n'a pas de masque pas de
surbourg part de charlotte pas de
protection pour le visage fait il nous
manque globalement de tous on se
débrouille actuellement on sait que dans
les services hospitaliers
ils sont au top de leur capacité et y
donne tout on le fait également en ville
après le reste que les politiques
veulent s'amuser à ce petit jeu de
questionnements franchement franchement
ça nous regarde pas ils sont tous
responsables soit parce qu'ils étaient
aux commandes et qu'ils ont mal fait
soit parce qu'ils étaient dans
l'opposition et qui n'ont pas su alerter
donc à partir de là ils sont tous
globalement responsable de la crise
sanitaire majeure que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
qui n'est que l'aboutissement d'une
crise sanitaire qui était larvé depuis
des années et des années et puis parfois
il faudra qu'il s'explique mais après
après la crise pour l'instant il faut
s'occuper des patients